Tuesday sometime after 2 A.M the Nova
kahovka Dam has been partially breached
explosions appear to be ongoing note the
blast on the left of the screen and the
pylon on the right
by Dawn the pylons gone the breach has
widened much more of the dam overwhelmed
by water exactly what caused this
disaster is the focus of intense
scrutiny the answer could have grave
implications for what happens next in
this war
the Russians say the ukrainians did it
with artillery in particular American
supplied High Mars Precision guided
artillery used by Ukraine it's believed
once already to hit the dam in November
so what are we seeing here we're seeing
the dam breached the dam has been
breached we've just seen an explosion
which you know is probably a mine that's
about the sort of size of explosion uh
importantly it's gone straight up so
it's not an artillery shell there simply
isn't the evidence to suggest the
ukrainians did this with artillery fire
a deliberate and elaborate sabotage is a
much more plausible Theory this is a
very sophisticated structure it's been
designed to hold back millions of tons
of water it's been designed so that even
if there's a small breach it won't
become catastrophic we have a
catastrophic breach here there has been
this footage of explosions in the water
near the dam which Russians say is
evidence of Ukrainian shelling
but the smoke plume is vertical most
likely these are dislodged mines
exploding in the water ukrainians have
been warning residents about the dangers
of floating mines since the breach
happened alternatively could Mother
Nature have been responsible this graph
shows that rainfall and water levels in
the dam have been unusually high
recently did that somehow cause the dam
to fail as some have suggested
not likely says this expert on
Structural Engineering it's two sections
that have been bridged in the dam itself
whether one explosion caused you know a
sort of riveting effect on the the
concrete structure itself if natural
causes can be ruled out and the
ukrainians weren't responsible what's
left is sabotaged by the Russians they
have the most to benefit as it could
delay the ukrainians counter-offensive
on this front by up to two months
that conclusion though poses an
unsettling question if Russians were
prepared to blow up a dam with all the
destruction that's caused for only
temporary tactical gain what else are
they capable of and what are they
planning next
Dominic wagorn Sky News